Right?
Well those are big problems,
especially the loss of unsupervised play.
It's not,
it's not obvious at all how
that might be addressed.
Yes it is.
Okay,
good.
Good.
Everyone should just by Lenore skinnies,
he's book free range kids and then they
should loosen up and give their kids
more unsupervised time.
Now you can't do this alone.
You'll be arrested.
I tried to get my son to go out across
the street to buy groceries when he was
nine years old and he'd say liquid.
You know,
Daddy,
people look at me funny there.
There were no other kids out there.
Um,
and so Lenore has started a fantastic
organization called let grow.
So if you were to go to let grow.org,
okay,
we'll put all this in the description,
all of these things,
right?
So I'm on the board of it as an advisor,
Peter Gray,
uh,
an expert on,
on play is on the board and
they're doing these simple things.
Simple,
simple things like you convinced the
school to just open up the playground an
hour early or keep it open after school.
Why should kids always have organized
activities and soccer practice?
Just give them a place to play
where there's a nurse available.
If someone gets hurt,
there is an adult but
he's not supervising.
He's just over there.
So don't worry parents,
there is an adult,
but beyond that do what they want.
And they just started
this a few weeks ago.
The results are fantastic.
The kids are having so much fun,
they are becoming more independent,
they're more willing to
do projects on their own.
It's working out great.
So that's really good
to do this on your own.
But the thing is we all
know something's wrong.
So those are very practical.
That's very practical piece of advice for,
for schools.
It's like open up the
unsupervised play facilities and,
and,
and facilitate their use.
That's right.
Give,
give everyone a place which is safe.
And by safe,
I mean physically safe.
Never use the word safety to
describe emotions and ideas.
Safety means physical safety.
So you've got to provide a physically
safe place for the kids to play.
And beyond that you let them go.
Now there will arise problems of bullying.
So if it's repeated harassment,
oh,
you know,
well I know a book about that,
which it's by Dan always called bullying,
what we know and what we can do about it.
And it was written,
it's got to be 30 years ago
and always cut the rope,
the,
the uh,
the incidents of bullying in the
Scandinavian countries down by 50%.
And he really,
really targets what bullying means.
So he's not a safe space guy by
any stretch of the imagination.
I don't know what the origins of it are.
I know that valuations of his program
in America show it anywhere from zero to
20% reductions and the effects are much
smaller in the u s in the u s yeah.
The question is whether or not they were
able to implement them with the rigor
he did in the u s but bullying programs
are part of the problem because bullying
clearly is a problem.
We need to do something about it,
but because we have what's
called concept creep.
Yeah.
So,
so it's now back to your point,
concept creep looks like even,
yeah,
that's right.
Uh,
so now it's the case that if,
if kids don't invite,
if some kids want to do something
and they don't invite another kid,
they've excluded that kid.
Right.
Well that could be bullying.
I've read of schools in Europe that
don't allow kids to have best friends for
exactly that reason.
Yeah.
Well,
because this is also something that
really bothers me about the misuse of the
IAT because it's not that easy to
distinguish in group preference,
which no one can,
no one went in their right mind would
want to eliminate in group preference
given that it governs your choice of mate
and your behavior towards your family
members,
let's say,
to distinguish that between outgroup
exclusion is no in no simple matter.
And to tell kids that they can't have
a best friend is another thing that
interferes with an
important part of their,
that's right.
Yeah.
I think both of us have spent a lot
of time looking at ancient wisdom at,
at the writings of,
of people long ago.
Uh,
and I often come back to Aristotle's
claim that any virtue carried to extremes
becomes advice.
So inclusion is a good thing if people
are being excluded because they have a
physical stigma or,
or they're overweight or their skin color.
So,
you know,
we need to be looking at the
reasons why kids are excluded.
But if you say inclusion
is the primary virtue,
inclusion over everything else.
And so if those two best
friends are excluding others,
no more best friends,
this is madness.
This is a vice.
So I think that inclusion,
again,
you know,
it's a virtue unless
it's carried to extremes.